I know a lot of fans have a lot of
questions which I guess is why I'm here
so let's get right because this was last
Saw Tully and Kate last season at the
end of last season you were not on
speaking terms so where do we pick up on
season two
um and when we get the answers we've
been waiting for
era
um What routine it's what we do it's our
thing yeah uh you do you're gonna get
all of the answers
and it's crazy and I don't think it's
gonna be what you thought it was gonna
be and then sometime in your 40s you
realize there's no more u-turns
[Applause]
it's juicy
and You're gonna laugh and you're gonna
cry and you're gonna do all of the
things well Catherine I know that there
was a little bit of a time job like
where does season two pick up and you
know are you retracing steps to figure
out why they kind of like are not on
speaking terms for sure and it's kind of
moving through the decades and the
timelines so
um we'll kind of get to Journey with
them through all that backstory
that led us to that moment I can only
imagine for you too because obviously I
could tell when Sarah signed onto the
zoom you guys are close you guys are
buds you know so yeah and in this show
your characters they may be best friends
but they're not always so good to each
other uh so I mean what's that like as
an actor to kind of play up the maybe
the the uglier or more Dynamic parts of
this relationship Sarah
yeah that's one of my favorite Parts
about it you see this
Perfectly Imperfect friendship that's
real you know it's not glossy and
obviously where we start off in this
season
um it's really rough it's at the the
hardest point in their friendship that
they've ever been and you honestly don't
know like if they will come back from it
and to have two people that are so
Inseparable and each other's everything
and so close go through something that
big I mean it feels like you know it
would be so fun just to get every new
script because it's very much like
season one
these ones all end on a cliffhanger so I
finished one I'd be like but wait
can I have it next that's how you'll get
us that's how you keep watching we gotta
find out yeah next one starting in three
two one
what's that like for you I mean I have
to imagine it's kind of hard to be mean
to Sarah
oh my God it's impossible right
um you know it's so funny I was thinking
like it literally brings me to tears and
this trailers when I watched it started
making me cry again because I missed
I miss them so much that particular part
of the storyline was really hard for me
to to show up and not
you know to not have that that
connection between these two that I had
started to feel was like they're real
people and it's a real thing and now
they're mad at each other and it was
hard well speaking of Tears we know that
season two is also the last I mean
that's got to be hard how emotional is
it for you guys to say goodbye to this
project and to this cast and crew
it was so hard I mean we had gotten all
so close it's part of what I loved about
getting to film this season it's such a
different experience coming back
you are the best friend a girl could ask
for because you already have that
foundation and obviously it's not always
the case but it certainly was in this
one everybody it just worked it was one
of those best case scenarios where like
all of the elements kind of came
together where you know you love the
character you get to play and the
writing and the show and the story and
all of the things but then also the
people I mean we you know had some
pretty regular good epic game nights at
my house that then turned into a long
night dance parties I love it everyone
you know actually delete those videos
aren't you yes and I love my fans truly
you've been served
anyway I could take a picture with you
and you know we went in knowing like
this is it there is a there's an end to
the story and we're telling it so we
knew
um and I think we did I mean I feel like
I did and Sarah did and I I think the
rest of the cast did too and the crew
like just really savor it
um and really try to um be present and
be in the moment with everybody because
we do it would wasn't going to be
forever sure uh Catherine I have to say
we love you as a brunette are we going
back and forth are we doing both I mean
it's exhausting
I change it like every three months and
my poor kid they're like who are you now
um I was supposed to actually go
brunette again last night and then um
had to cancel that hair appointment so
the next time you see me I'm probably
gonna be a brunette I don't know
live your life I say yeah whatever
whatever floats your boat in the that
week I should say yeah
your girls sisters we're best friends
don't ever take that for granted not
everyone gets a best friend you know
there's such an important message here
with this show though you know looking
at it it is about friendship it is about
growing up and all of the highs and lows
of those relationships you know and as
moms yourselves did the show make you
think about you know uh your own kids
and and what life lessons you hope to
kind of instill in them I mean for sure
I think you know this this show and this
relationship
um and even the relationship that that
Sarah and I formed through working
together like it just reminded me how
valuable and how important
um those those female relationships are
those you know friendships are and Sarah
has a best friend that she's had like
her whole life I have a best friend I've
had my whole life and now we have each
other and we're each other's best friend
and
and I want that so much for my girls
because I think you know it's difficult
for women to form those bonds sometimes
especially at Young ages you know those
sort of tumultuous teenage years when
everybody's just trying to figure out
who they are and there's them you know
the mean girl syndrome there's the
clicks and the popularity contests and
all this this stuff that can that can um
kind of ruin your faith in that kind of
relationship and this reminded me like
no those relationships do exist they are
important and they are important to
Foster and so I'm really
pushing my daughters to be that girl for
someone else you know well Catherine I
have to ask you about another best
friend act I don't know if you realize
this but next year marks 15 years since
27 Dresses I love his patient love is
kind
love means slowly losing your mind what
is it you do again I'm a writer right
no it's sad they're making me feel old
man no how amazing is it that that movie
really just has stood the test of time
people are still so obsessed with it
like that's got to feel really good oh
my god it feels so good I didn't realize
they were so thank you
a good movie it's such a good movie it
was a fun one we I think yes my husband
and I just watched it recently it was on
TV and I said let's just watch it I mean
I hadn't seen it since probably it came
out and that was another one of those
extraordinary experiences and I do think
often like it's starting to be cute for
me wait a minute I think when you had
that much fun with the people on set and
you're enjoying each other so much and
you're you're enjoying the story so much
it shows and it and it I don't know
those are those have been the most
successes I've had with me like I think
this show and 27 Dresses because
um I don't know maybe it's just a spirit
thing you can sense the spirit of fun
we're all having
foreign